ah il se moque pas de nous chez google
et se moque pas de nous comment ça va
comment est ce que ça roule aujourd'hui
il se manque pas nous avec un nouveau
pic celle qui était présentée il ya
quelques semaines j'étais à la confier
google mais regrette d'ailleurs de
m'avoir invité chez eux pour découvrir à
ste mois de mai il semble que celle ci
ça il est là il est beau regardez
regardez comme il est beau il est beau
quand même c'est très marrant parce que
sur un marché où les smartphones se
ressemblent beaucoup particulièrement en
ce moment avec des blogs photos de ce
côté là et bien google fait les choses
différemment et si on la vit déjà avec
le pixel six pros qui est sorti un petit
moment on retrouve le même esprit c'est
à dire cette espèce de grandes barres en
eau dans lequel votre module photo et
planqués et je trouve ça mal hein parce
qu'en fait on retrouve quelque chose
d'un peu particulier google ici un peu
particulier aux pixels et qui fonctionne
et qui fonctionne vachement bien alors
aujourd'hui on parle pas du procès un
smartphone qui est déjà sorti
aujourd'hui on se sent vraiment sur le
pixel si ça parce que et on l'avait pas
lu mais une année on est petit pixel 5 a
en fait c'est vachement bien parce que
google lorsqu'il vous sortez leur gros
modèles il sortait un modèle à six mois
après un modèle un peu plus milieu de
gamme mais en gardant un très gros focus
au niveau de la qualité photo ll c'est
vraiment ce qui se continue à faire ici
c'est à dire que montre les muscles on
garde ce que google sait faire c'est
faire mieux notamment du logiciel n'est
pas que et sans on l'a vu déjà l'année
dernière avec le google pixels si ces
pixels six pros avec leurs premières
puces 100% google la google tel sort
plus le coprocesseur titan m2 pour la
sécurité donc ça c'est vachement bien
c'est la même chose là dedans donc on va
regarder on va le détail et je dois vous
dire aujourd'hui s'il faut se
positionner sur le google pixels si ça
ou pas du tout on y va
[Musique]
regardez ça c'est marrant alors series
l'aiment bien comme ça parce qu'il a un
dock est très atypique très à part pour
autant il prend quand même vachement les
traces de doigts la poussière aime bien
venir se mettre deux suspects espèce de
fusion que la poussière ça doit lui
faire gagner des petites cochonneries
qui sont venus se positionner là et que
on vient balayer de son doigt alors moi
ce que je vous recommande quand même
c'est de venir mettre une coque de
protection et google en a une qui est
plutôt sympa de toute simple ça coûte 29
balles vous la mettez et s'avoue le
protège et vous garder le même esprit
rentre là mon petit lapin est comme ça
vous pouvez prendre et le jeter alors on
va pas s'amuser à le jeter c'est pas le
but mais si vous voulez jeter pouvait le
jeu est alors on vient d'enlever pour la
vidéo comme ça ça m'évitera de venir
jeter et vous un smartphone qui est
sympa de soi qui est très sympa jamais a
dit pas ce que vous en pensez tout de
suite de deux de ce loup au niveau de ce
smartphone regardez c'est très marrant
parce que regarder il ya toute une
partie la ksf ici là où on voit le
module photo alors je vous le dis une
fois de plus sans les traces doivent pas
trop trop les craintes mais moi j'aime
bien je trouve ça très joli j'aime bien
ce design j'aime bien ce look pareil au
niveau de l'écran devant j'aime bien
alors c'est toute une partie logicielle
ces espèces d'heure qui est énorme le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
déverrouille rapidement que tous les
widgets ya plein de widgets pouvait
venir ajouté alors moi j'aime bien c'est
sympa ça permet de personnaliser son
expérience et 6 aigles android 12 tout
en sachant qu'ils sont en train de faire
la migration chez google en ce moment
pour passer sur android 13 donc si vous
achetez un pixel si ça et bien vous
allez pouvoir avoir android 13 avant les
autres et ça c'est chouette et des
widgets il y en a des tonnes de tous les
côtés vous laissez votre doigt appuyé
vous regardez vous avez ou jet et y en a
pleins regarder sur toutes les
thématiques ça va être l'agenda ça va
être sur chrome le drive l'horloger
compagnie les photos si vous voulez
mettre des widgets vous pouvez mettre
des widgets une tronche de chiens comme
ça ça fait toujours plaisir donc ça
c'est vachement bien et c'est très
chouette pareil la traduction pouvait le
mettre google trad c'est très facile si
vous voyez vous voulez traduire quelques
actions très rapide très simple et je
trouve ça une fois de plus très efficace
et ça marche bien donc ça vient
augmenter et améliorer significativement
toute l'expérience qu'on va voir ici du
côté d'android alors je vais pas vous
parler d'android en long en large et en
travers je pense que vous connaissez
c'est l'expérience logiciel de google
qui est intégré un peu partout sur tous
les smartphones or mais évidemment les
iphone et or pas vraiment hors mais qui
va potentiellement être hors des
smartphones de huawei un jour peut-être
on sait pas on verra ça pourrait arriver
et c'est une très belle expérience
logiciel qui marche bien non je peux pas
vous en parler pendant des heures pour
ce sera une vidéo pour se parler
d'android 13 très très très bientôt mais
ça marche bien c'est cool c'est efficace
et ça c'est très chouette moi ce que
j'aime bien ici déjà c'est le design de
ce smartphone vous lisez au niveau du
dos mais je vous le dis également du
côté de lavande à la petite caméra s'est
perforé ici un petit manteau en bas bon
ok ça marche il est chouette il a
vraiment une super jolie gueule alors
maintenant je dirais que le plus beau
ceux ci dessus à l'intérieur et c'est là
que ça nous intéresse réellement
pourquoi et oui ça c'est la question
parce que la force de ce smartphone là
c'est le processeur qu'on a à
l'intérieur et c'est vachement
intéressant parce que on l'a vu avec le
pixel six spectacles six pros je vous le
disais c'est la première fois que google
nous pond un processeur maison c'est le
google tensor et vous avez exactement le
même processeur que dans le smartphone
le plus haut de gamme de google qui
situait juste là c'est le pixel syspro
donc là vous avez la même performance
nos côtés et de l'autre la seule
différence est que sur le pixel si ça
vous avez si giga de ram sur le pro vous
avez douzy adam et sur le pixel 6 vous
avez 8 gigas de ram donc un peu moins de
fluidité c'est vrai mais on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme on va pas
tout avoir on va pas tout attendre de
lui pour autant vous avez le même
stockage 128 go de stockage de côté et
de l'autre avec une technologie qui
marchent vachement bien celle ufs trois
points donc c'est un smartphone qui va
aller très bien pour plein d'usagé il
faut quand même savoir ici que ce
processeur il est performant et surtout
adapté aux usages google la traduction
en ligne tout ce que vous allez à bord
avec google je vous en parle dans
quelques instants c'est pas le
processeur le plus performant en terme
de perte brute si vous voulez de la
perte brute vous allez sur un qualcomm
snapdragon 8 + jane un là vous aurez
tous qui sera un peu plus sauvage donc
il y à certains jeux les jeux les plus
gourmands où vous irez un peu moins loin
c'est le surtout qu'il faut savoir ici
l'autre truc il faut savoir ici ça un
peu à regret c'est que en fait vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement de 60 hertz
alors vous me direz broc et sur son taux
ne marche pas trop mal sauf que ce
smartphone et coûte quand même le plus
de paris par coeur ces 459 euros 459
euros vous avez un smartphone avec juste
un taux de rafraîchissement 60r et le 60
hertz le basique de basic depuis des
années donc je trouve ça dommage que
google n'ait pas fait l'effort de mettre
90 alors pourquoi est ce qu'ils n'ont
pas fait lors d'une pour préserver les
marges et 2 pour la gamme du coup vous
avez un pixel si ça avec du 60 m un
pixel 6 avec du 90e c'est un pixel six
pros avec du sang va être bon il ya
d'autres différences au niveau des
technologies notamment sur le pij à six
pros vous avez dale ltp bref passons un
peu l'histoire ici vous n'avez pas le
tout infléchissement qui va porter le
plus de fluidité et ses comparses
qu'aujourd'hui les gens quand ils
viennent naviguer je pense notamment au
resserrement sur instagram ou sur des
gens on veut de la fluidité maximale dès
lors que les jeux le permettent et ici
un truc qui me frustre un peu alors
c'est des choix il a fallu opérer des
choix en termes de joudes une fois de
plus de gamme en termes de coût en
termes de marges pour vous proposer un
truc qui est très bien et ça bon c'est
le truc qui est un peu dommage pour que
notre côté le choix de laisser leurs
gouvernants sort partout c'est bien mais
ça me paraît tellement logique maître
queux de 60 heures voilà je sais pas je
suis un peu frustré toujours bien aimé
au moins un minimum à 90 hier bon voilà
on peut pas tout avoir a ajouté deux
savoie la dalle je trouve très très bien
bien calibré elle est super bonne
qualité les couleurs sont justes les
noirs sont profonds c'est l'oled rien à
redire là dessus j'ai peut-être lui
reprocher un petit manque de luminosité
alors ça c'est vraiment histoire de
chipoter lorsque je viens en plein
soleil voyait par moments je trouve que
à il lui en manque un petit peu c'est
vraiment le petit reproche que je devais
faire parce que le reste c'est quand
même plutôt vachement bien l'expérience
au jeu sommes plus pas de changement
pour un niveau de gamme ça reste très
très médium attention vous allez hop à
la principale ont par leurs deux enfants
côté ça fait le taff une fois de plus ce
que je vous conseille quand même c'est
de venir à vous connecter en bluetooth
bluetooth 5.2 bon la fiche technique est
belle très très simple c'est gras très
très bien ici côté batterie on a une
batterie de 4400 10 millions pme
recrutent aussi un peu un peu dommage
vous avez de la recharge rapide mais pas
assez rapides on n'est pas sur des 65
watts on n'est même pas sûr du 25 watts
falloir s'armer un petit peu de patience
c'est un peu le regret qu'on pouvoir
avoir ici à côté de ça l'autonomie de ce
smartphone est quand même plutôt bien
convenable donc ça va bien une journée
et demie sans problème une fois de plus
ça va dépendre de vous ils vous usages
et puis je vous le disais tout à l'heure
le truc est vraiment bien c'est que
google fait du google et google fait
drôlement bien du booklet à ce que
google et google ben oui forcément c'est
très très logique ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que vous avez des mises à jour
de sécurité pendant au moins cinq ans
pendant cinq ans vous êtes peinard en
termes de sécurité la sécurité elle est
là je voulais dit en plus avec la puce
titan m2 pas de souci là-dessus contre
phishing vous êtes protégé contre pas
mal de trucs vous êtes protégé peut-être
quand même attention vous à ce que vous
faites est à là où vous allez bien
évidemment expérience 100%
personnalisable grâce à un matériel ou
qu'on a depuis android 12 et puis le
truc qui est vachement intéressant c'est
que ils nous font un truc google
s'appelle les drogues futur c'est à dire
c'est des petites nouveautés qui vont
venir implémenté dans leurs smartphones
tous les trois mois et tous les trois
mois passe vous avez un nouveauté qui
apparut alors ils vont pas voulu dire
ils vont pas vous mettre un petit pop-up
tiens il ya cette nouveauté qui arrivait
avec la mise à jour ça ils le font pas
c'est dommage il devrait le faire
d'ailleurs parce qu'en fait vous à des
nouveautés qui sont super intéressante
super pertinentes et vous ne le savez
pas il faut aller voir chez google pour
le sam à fond les valeurs site et j'ai
dommage qu'ils communiquent pas dessus
il faudrait vraiment qu'ils viennent
communiquer dessus d'ailleurs je vous ai
fait une vidéo on a fait un live en
partenariat avec google et la fnac qui a
pas très longtemps où on vous présentait
on parce que j'étais pas tout seul et on
vous montrer les dernières robes futur
dont toutes les fonctionnalités qui sont
arrivés en plus depuis la sortie des
pixels si ces pixels syspro jusqu'à je
crois que c'est jusqu'au moins deux mois
d'avril moine mais c'était par là à peu
près donc aller jeter un oeil c'est
vachement intéressant vous à découvrir
plein de choses on peut venir effacé
quelqu'un sur la photo directement
toutes les nouveautés que vous avez en
terme de traduction tout ce qui va être
également je crois voiture connectée il
ya plein de choses qui sont vachement
intéressante allez jeter un coup d'oeil
à ce live qui est sur ma chaîne youtube
surtout aller jeter un coup d'oeil sur
le site de google parce que tous les
trois mois je vous dis vous pousse des
nouveautés c'est très chouette un truc
tout con par exemple que fait vachement
bien google et cesser de la traduction
lorsque vous êtes au plat par exemple
vous venez ici vous venez dans ce
système et vous allez dans traduction
instantanée est bien ici vous pouvez
venir choisir des langues que vous allez
venir traduire alors moi je vous ai mis
de l'anglais l'espagnol et lorsque vous
retrouver dans un pays étranger bien
vous avez téléchargé volant parce qu'il
faut venir les télécharger et vous avez
vachement le monde attendait
regardez-moi ça on ne sait pas combien
donc vous peur du suédois pouvoir du
tabou par du tchèque ou par l albanais
pour avoir de l'espéranto du finnois du
gallois du grec du hongrois bref
vachement de langue donc lorsque vous
allez venir bouger dans le monde entier
c'est vachement pratique parce que vous
allez pouvoir dire communiquer
facilement si par exemple vous avez un
menu qui a écrit j'en sais rien moi en
chinois et bien vous prenez votre
smartphone vous prenez pas une photo
vous mettez de suez en live ça vous
traduire à tous et c'est super bien donc
il ya plein de petites fonctionne et est
plein de petits trucs vachement pratique
vous propose google ici ou en plus comme
vous pouvez le mettre en vedette et bien
pour la trad et pour le voyage ça vous
emmène vraiment au bout du monde et
c'est vraiment génial et autre point qui
est génial en plus de l'ouest c'est
toute la partie photo c'est vraiment
l'article google est très très fort vous
avez un double capteur de 12 mégapixels
ici alors autant sur le pixel 6 et 6
assists propose un capteur principal de
50 méga pixels et on faisait du pixel
bening se dire qu'on est regroupé quatre
pixels en main pour sortir une photo
avec un peu plus de 12 mégapixels si
c'est un capteur 12 mégapixels et enfin
2 capteur de 12 millions pixels on va
avoir une qualité qui sera un peu
moindre mais on sait que chez google ce
qui marche à la belle évidemment il faut
des capteurs être les quatorze bonne
qualité et la force de google c'est
l'algorithme c'est tout le travail
derrière toute la connaissance qu'ils
ont tout l'iac vous avez derrière qui va
vous sortir des photos mais absolument
incroyable de jour comme de nuit alors
j'ai fait un peu le tour du monde pour
bien vous montrer quelques photos je me
suis baladée hp s'est fait plaisir en
vacances regarde et vous allez voir
c'est vachement intéressant là on est à
new york on et schémas six autres qu'on
ait deux voir schéma ci ce parce qu'on
n'est pas dedans puisque on va le
bâtiment l'extérieur c'est assez logique
il rendu correct grand angle ultra
grand-angle on a bien les nuages tout va
plutôt bien très beau boulot de la part
de google là dessus on peut venir zoom
et un petit peu mais c'est du zoom
numérique donc on va éviter de première
zone et sans qu'on va venir dégradé à la
qualité je trouve que dans l'ensemble et
ce sont bien de jour comme de nuit il a
agit alors de nuit j'ai deux trois
petites remarques à faire au niveau des
lumières comme ça voyez il a eu un petit
peu de mal on va le voir sur quelques
photos il ya des photos on n'a pas ça du
tout mais à quelques photos où il a un
peu souffert voilà ici typiquement je
pense qu'il a un peu souffert c'est des
choses qui sont corrigées après par des
mises à jour dont que ça va être corrigé
regardez là c'est pareil la lumière il a
un peu souffert pareil la même chose ici
en arrière-plan ça s'est un peu tous que
je suis venu remarquer ici sinon dans
l'ensemble c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal avec pareil la voyez toutes les
lumières là au niveau des vendeurs de
hot-dogs et vendeurs de glaces bon il a
fait un peu la gueule ça je trouve déjà
beaucoup mieux vous avez bien
l'employeur state building derrière
l'âge de crois qu'on met sur la 6e
avenue si je ne me trompe pas voyez
voilà ça c'est tous ces petits trucs là
là qui sont un poil relou n'est que mon
voilà vous allez voir qu'à d'autres
photos après je voulais montrer là on
continue la balade on est à coney island
c'est la plage de new york et qui est en
dessous de brooklyn est forcément vous
allez voir que de plein jour les photos
sont très bien très belle ça marche bien
et c'est un excellent photophone que ce
soit sur le grand temps ou sur l'ultra
grand temps que vous avez ici et on sort
très très jolies photos voyez tour sort
très bien que ce soit le ciel que ce
soit après la photo elle tresse
répondait en plein été il ya de la
lumière tout est 100 % optimisée et ça
marche super bien la regarder grand
angle ultra grand-angle on vient se
rapprocher un petit peu puis trop et
quand c'est trop ça va pas pas ici
grand-angle ultra-grand-angle on a bien
la plage de coney island tout au fond là
alors là on peut se rapprocher pour voir
un peu le roller coaster qui est là
s'appelle cyclone vous avez cette espèce
de grand noir ses grandes roues est très
marrante petit aparté parce qu'en fait
là vous avez les petits wagons qui vont
se balader mais enfin quand ils arrivent
en eau après ils ont un petit chemin à
faire à l'intérieur ça fait comme un
espèce de grand
dans la grande roue parce qu'en fait ils
vont venir descendre à l'intérieur
bouger alors bon ça bouge un peu comme
ça j'ai pas fait j'aurais bien aimé
parce que je pense qu'en termes de
sensations ça va être quand même pas des
yeux cette histoire l'a ensuite ça je
voulais vraiment venir tester avec le
mode portrait après ça la bière connu ça
bien des torts et donc ça fonctionne
toujours la plage de coney island ici
d'un côté de tacles très grand-angle et
là il y en a qui sont complètement en
l'air la vague et qui sont repartis avec
la boule soustrot et on l'a bien c est
ça marche donc une fois de plus je
trouve que le rendu est là est vraiment
vraiment de bonne qualité alors je passe
un peu on passe ensuite chez une attente
pour avoir un tout les hot dogs qui sont
hyper souhaite un peu de nourriture
aussi qu'on peut venir ajouté bon on va
vite et se rapprocher trop près et là de
la même manière quelques petites
lumières dont new york la nuit là je
vous emmène ensuite au mexique avec
malheureusement quelques stars igas sur
la plage mais dans l'ensemble le rendu
est là elle rendu vraiment ça parle ça
c'est un mode un peu à part c'est un
mode globe le mode sphère est en fait ce
mode les fellahs à la regarder
directement alors je vous montre vite
fait dans votre appareil photo vous
allez là et dans les modes vous avez
photosphère ça vous fait une photo en
rond en fait avec votre smartphone vous
allez venir prendre des photos de tout
autour de vous et après vous aura côté
assez immersif on navigue en dedans ce
qui fait que là j'ai une photo ce faire
aux plats nommé comme ça et là je me
mets dedans et là je peux retourner en
vacances la voyez je suis sur mon hôtel
je suis au bord de la plage et vous
voyez exactement ce que je voyais alors
ça je les packs à cartographier ces seul
trou et je m'en suis pas rendu compte
donc j'ai simple un milieu c'est con
c'est la merde mais sinon voyez j'ai le
ciel j'ai mes pindar dans le sol et puis
j'ai surtout toute la plage là où j'ai
passé mes vacances et qui était juste
hyper cool avec ton petit à faire
briller mais tombent au sol et c'était
juste vachement bien donc cette photo ce
faire elle est sympa parce qu'on peut
vraiment se replonger dans un endroit
dans un bon ici et maintenant et ça je
trouve ça cool dont vous voyez qu'en
terme de photos je trouve qu'ils ont
bien bossé chez vous gueulez une fois de
plus et ça il le maîtrisait déjà on
l'avait vu avec le plus c'est le cas
traces étaient très très bien il ya pas
eu de pixels 5a le pixel si ça continue
dans cette ligne là et vous avez un très
bon photophone dans le milieu de gamme
qui est un peu passe partout qui sera
vous prendre de très bonnes photos quels
que soient les conditions je vous dis
quelques petits trucs que j'appelle au
niveau de la retenue mais ça je pense
qu'une bonne vieille mise à jour si vous
courez sous sa verrière centrale taf
d'autant plus qu'ils ont bossé sur un
truc à une fois plus avec l'algorithme
on l'a déjà vu ça c'est sûr pixels 6 tc
6 pauvres et on au niveau de la peau
pour que quel que soit votre carnation
pour quelle que soit la couleur de votre
peau et bien vous est quelque chose qui
soit très juste très vrai bonne qualité
vous avez également de lentilles flou
bref il ya pas mal de choses logiciels
qui sont là totalement optimisé pour
maximiser vos photos tout en sachant
qu'ici vous avez la possibilité de
mettre une seule carte sim et unis si
vous avez du wifi 6e ça c'est cool wifi
six wi fi 6e dans le milieu de gamme
plutôt a donc il faut vraiment venir
souligner du nfc de la 5g google case
pour venir castet sur tous vos appareils
il est certifié également ip67 et je
vous le dis est disponible au tarif de
459 euros alors la question c'est est-ce
que ce google pixels si ça est bien
réussie pour moi la réponse c'est oui il
est bien réussi il est peut être fait
pour vous si vous voulez une expérience
google si vous aimez vos gueules si vous
utilisez les services google et si vous
voulez tous les services de google à un
tarif maîtrisé à 159 euros ça reste
quand même beaucoup d'argent mais ça
reste maîtrisée là vous avez un truc est
vachement bien et qui vous sortira de
très jolies photos donc pour moi c'est
un des meilleur photophone dans cette
gamme de prix six des meilleurs donc si
vous voulez un joli appareil passe
partout avec un bel écran et une super
qualité et de la performance qui n'a
rien à envier aux pixels six pros et
bien vous pouvez aller sur le google
pixels si ça voilà j'ai tout raconté
qu'il pense pas avant quelques jours de
ça on se parle des pixels bugs pro sont
les écouteurs nouvelle expérience aussi
de chez google au niveau de l'audio on
s'en parle bientôt donc venez vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait et si
c'est déjà fait penser à activer la
cloche pour notifier que cette vidéo la
rivera ça c'est cool dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez de ce google pixels
si ça en bas en commentaire est ce qu'il
vous plaît ce que vous avez déjà eu un
smartphone de google que ce soit un
pixel 3 pixels 3-1 pixels syspro que ce
soit un pixel 5 dites moi tout ça en bas
en commentaire succès le cadre que ça
j'ai encore marqué le mois et puis c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre retour puis ça
permet de répondre aux questions et
d'alimenter le débat pour tous dire au
niveau des google pixels 6 et les pixels
si ça ici ça c'est chouette allez je
vous embrasse pris soin de vous et à
très bientôt et bio beaucoup d'amour
ciao
[Musique]